syndra Acacio cortez is the youngest
member of congress she turned 30 just a
couple of weeks ago she's barely old
enough to rent a car and yet already
she's one of the most powerful
politicians in America 18 months ago
nobody in Washington had heard of the
green New Deal today it's at the very
center of the Democratic agenda
Acacio Cortez did that so there's a
reason she's famous it's not just hype
she's impressive in a lot of ways and
even if you disagree with her you ought
to admit that she's legitimately tough
for one thing strength is a prerequisite
for success in politics as in life
Acacio Cortez is she's one of the only
Democrats in the house who's totally
unintimidating by Nancy Pelosi when she
got to Washington party bosses tried to
make her moderator views for public
consumption but she refused
unlike most members of Congress Acacio
Cortes actually believes most of what
she says she understands that something
profound has gone wrong in America the
country is dangerously unequal fixing
that will require going to war with the
entrenched establishment which is
currently profiting from the status quo
Acacio Cortez is happy to do that when
Amazon decided to demand subsidies nor
to come to New York she was one of the
very few who asked why we would send tax
dollars to the world's richest man when
all the fashionable people in her party
decided that Elizabeth Warren should be
the nominee
Acacio Cortes endorsed Bernie she's an
independent spirit one of the very few
in Washington and it's easy to see what
young people listen to her and in the
end that is the problem with Alexandria
Acacio Cortez he's not her economic
views the ones that get all the
attention yes she's a wild-eyed
left-winger who's pushing socialism on
the country her ideas may be stupid and
wrong we think they are but they're
still undeniably ideas you could debate
them we often do the problem is the rest
of what she says there's a darker side
to Acacio Cortez and it has nothing to
do with the green New Deal she's an
unapologetic bigot someone who attacks
others for the way they were born
there's nothing legitimate about that
you can't debate bigotry it's pure
poison it's terrifying to think that
someone who's open racism has become a
role model for our young people but that
is exact
what has happened and has been happening
since Acacio Cortez arrived on the
public stage during her first run for
Congress last year Acacio Cortez
suggested that the incumbent who held
the seat didn't deserve to be in
Congress because he was the wrong race
by Election Day her opponent was
literally apologizing for his own skin
color when he accused Acacio Cortez of
making the election about race she
didn't run from it quote it is about
race end quote not so long ago a
campaign like that would have been
considered deeply immoral the press
would have hounded Acacio Cortez until
she apologized or dropped out but not
anymore
a ruling class no longer recognizes
universal standards of any kind
racism they've decided cuts only one way
so they ignored Acacio Cortez's race
baiting and she got elected over time
like any untreated virus her bigotry
grew more inflamed here was Acacio
Cortez just last week in a public
hearing explaining that actually global
climate change is the fault of a
specific racial group watch do we see
largely that it's the global South and
communities of color that may be bearing
the brunt of the initial havoc from
climate change without a doubt without a
doubt and in terms of of that wealth the
people who are producing climate change
the folks that are responsible for the
largest amount of emissions or
communities or corporations they tend to
be predominantly white correct yes and
every study backs that up the people
that are producing climate change and go
that's right those people the ones
destroying the earth driving entire
species to extinction killing children
ever notice how all those people look
alike they've got something in common
don't they that's right they're the same
color that's what she's saying
standards have changed so much that it's
hard to say something genuinely shocking
in this country anymore but that
qualifies for all the hysteria but you
hear about how the president is a racist
the all Trump has never say to anything
close to that nothing close to his
bigoted and vicious as that the people
wrecking the world are all of one race
who talks like that in fact it's hard to
think of anyone
in American life saying anything that
disgusting and foolish and dangerous if
so exactly what would it be
and yet and here's the amazing part
nobody seemed to even notice when Acacio
Cortez said that in the middle of a
congressional hearing a ruler's acted
like it was all totally normal because
increasingly for them it is normal this
is an ominous development for this
country talk like this will destroy us
it has come close before as you know
it's possible that a Kazuya Cortez
doesn't really know what she's saying
you'd like to think that she doesn't
maybe she's just young and lacking
wisdom and can't hear herself the
problem is that others can hear her
clearly
every time she encourages her followers
to hate and distrust other people based
on their race some of them will and over
time this is how countries fall apart so
going forward here's a plea to
Alexandria Kazuya Cortes keep saying
what you think is true keep taking jabs
at the establishment in Washington even
those of us who disagree with you will
cheer you want but my gosh please for
the sake of the country and the children
you don't yet have please stop attacking
people for the color of their skin they
can't change who they are and neither
can you
we all have to live here together anyway
and we won't be able to if you keep this
up